the current line about artificial
intelligence is backwards the current
line about artificial intelligence is
that AI is going to replace all those
those useless low-skilled workers this
is what you hear from from people like
Yuval Harare or some of the world
economic foreign types that say oh you
know we're going to have all these
useless people in the future because of
Automation and so we'll just apply them
with drugs and video games usually what
they mean by useless people
the poor people the uneducated people
the service worker type people they're
going to be replaced by automation chat
GPT Wharton business school is showing
it's the opposite the useless people
are the white-collar workers in most
cases
not not not all of them but a lot of
them